hey everybody Doug Walker here you're
probably wondering where the NC is this
week well sadly there is not one because
I'm actually on vacation there will be a
new one next week and it won't be an
editorial it'll be a fledged uh you know
fully done review so um yeah no
editorial this week I apologize but at
the same time I want to give you guys
something so as you probably right in
the title this is uh my top ten most
attractive female characters in movies
TV shows whatever before I get started
bad uh just quick plug real fast there's
two cons coming up in July mention it
before but just in case you forgot
there's one in Chicago called
anime Midwest here's the website and the
information on that go check it out Brad
is gonna be there Luis is gonna be there
team four stars gonna be there Malcolm
and Tamara are gonna be there ginger oz
and all these great people Rob's gonna
be there so uh yeah check that out it's
gonna be a lot of fun kinetic on is also
happening in July that's uh been my
favorite con so far I love it
so many good people are gonna be there
like half the friggin half of your
childhood is gonna be there pretty much
now before I start I should make it very
clear that this is not actresses that
I'm necessarily talking about it's very
much the characters that they play um I
don't know what these women is so you
know for me to say oh well yeah they're
really hot really attractive it's I got
to know something about them I remember
why did the top 10 anime women's list
I'll get to real soon I'm sorry but um
some people were saying well that's
great about the character traits and
everything but how about just
attractiveness just how they look and
personality is like a big part of the
attractiveness and I think I said my
Facebook post like if you're judging
attractiveness just by how a person
looks that's like you know telling
someone don't don't show me the Super
Bowl just tell me what the score is that
majority of the fun you know is in the
personality is in the person you know
and not just how they look so but yes I
I like how you know I'm gonna certainly
sense if someone looks really good
gonna play a factor but it's it's not
the whole thing at least it's definitely
not for me and I just think this is fun
I think it's a fun thing to do it's sort
of fun to compare and contrast and
people also talk about the people they
find attractive so bla bla I've gone out
enough let's go ahead and get to the top
11 attractive female characters I say
top 11 or top 10 top 10 it's tough
Karen Allen from Raiders of the Lost Ark
somebody was asking me once how can you
find Karen Allen in that movie so
attractive because Indiana Jones
constantly has to save her a you know
people know I'm very anti damsel in
distress and it if it's not required or
doesn't seem fitting um and in this
movie I really think this is a big
testament to her performance because
they're right she has to be saved like a
dozen times in this movie but she is
still so badass and still so
contributing to everything and always
helping out indy and she's a tough
drinker and she's always finding ways to
get out and she's spunky and she's funny
and she's faithful and she's just
friggin awesome she's like you know
she's the action gal and she's just I
can't explain it I just know a lot of
his in the performance and nobody would
just look at her in this movie uh
despite whether or not you see her what
she does if you just look at her like
you see is still of her nobody be like
oh yeah that's the chick that any of
Jones has to save all the time is I know
you definitely get that from Willie from
Temple of Doom that's the annoying pain
in the ass that just always screams him
goes oh but tries to look pretty it's
not bullshit Karen Allen is awesome I
even thought she was awesome and kingdom
of the Crystal Skull it's like I wish
you did more don't get me wrong but it's
like seeing her back I'm like no cool
that's really cool she's spunky she's
awesome she gets in the action she's a
badass uh even though in the movie she
has to be saved a lot so uh I think a
lot of it is her performance and yeah
Marion's awesome Marion its Marion
fucking up a lot in this so far
Christon Dunson Eternal Sunshine of the
spotless mind um yeah I know a lot of
you gonna be like really all that shit
you gave Mary Jane Watson the spider-man
movies and stuff oh yeah I still hate
Mary Jane it she's a horribly written
character uh I seem to be finding out
more and more that Chris and Dunstan
care for the character either from from
what I've heard it's the Internet as
Ono's I don't know her so I have no idea
but um Kristen does it's one of those
actresses where it every time I see her
it's like you always see she's she's
doing her best with a role and you know
it's I think it usually works I think
she actually is very charming and good
at what she does even in something like
spider-man you know like I said I I
think in spider-man 3 is where you
started to see oh like she like she
really can act you know it's that sounds
bad cuz it's like the roles before she's
just given nothing and she's doing her
best with it but in three it's like no I
think she's holding this okay like she's
actually showing you know the tough side
of you know being with a superhero when
she needs the attention though she's
given him a ton of attention um so but
with this I we're talking TRO Sunshine
of the spotless mind uh that won't just
felt a bit more realistic she felt much
more like a real character and I just
remember her playing all sorts of
different angles in this I remember
being you know really angry and when
she's trying to stop Jim Carrey from
coming in and member being very playful
when she's just going and hanging out
with her friends I remember her being
very hopeful very sad when I won't give
away too much but there's somebody that
she likes in the film that she tries to
hit on and stuff and I remember how torn
apart she is when she figures out
something at the end she really runs the
gamut in this and I think she she
doesn't really well and it just seemed
like a very fully fleshed out character
even though it's kind of just one of the
side characters uh you know it's not Jim
Carrey it's not uh wasn't in Kate
Winslet or you know even Elijah Wood I
think it's more screen time than she
does but I think she did really well um
and uh she the more you find out about
her in the film and what she kind of
went through and what you put herself
through it
she becomes really interesting there's
some powder I she has these very sharp
eyes like some potato when she looks
angry when she's stopping Jim Carrey
from coming in I mean they can just
become like these death eyes like just
this sharp lasers going through you but
then they can also be like you know so
kind and comforting in other scenes and
yet I think she's really good I think
she's actually a very talented actress
and I know like I said I hate marriage I
think it's a terrible character but I
think she does very well in other roles
um I think she's gonna taking these
roles they're kind of nothing and
turning them into something or era's
best as a Sam Raimi spider-man movie cab
Chris and Duns I'm always like yeah
there's like she's really good what's
the movie where I always think of that
she actually comes through and just runs
the full gamut and that's or the one I'm
sure there's others um but that one in
particular I felt like she was kind of
uh you just saw every sort of side of
her even as a side care do you just saw
her do all these different emotions in
these different parts and she plays them
all great like I said it's where that's
a side character but I thought she
played so well it was definitely worth
mentioning so definitely good stuff
Jane Livas if I'm saying that correctly
I'm not entirely sure this is Daphne
moon from Frasier um a lot of it's the
accent I think a British accent is just
it's it's beautiful its elegant it's
it's just great um and again there is
sort of this I don't say naivete but
there is just sort of this blind
innocence to this character and how
everything just sort of excites her and
she's happy about everything and she
tries to always be in the best mood no
there is a naivete because yet Niles was
always trying to get with her and she
never catches on and I don't know I
think in a lot of ways I'm very naive to
a lot of stuff and I know I am and but
there what's that phrase ignorance is
bliss um there's some truth to that um
it can also cause a lot of trouble and
if you can avoid being ignorant it's
like please do you know I at least try
um but there is something where it's I
don't know when you're not aware of so
much is so much danger and so many so
much judgement and stuff you're just
kind of naturally happy you're not
thinking about all these things that can
sort of come after you or things that
might hurt you you're just sort of going
through life you know enjoying it and
that's sort of what I get out of her
she's just sort of very you know she's
happy with her job she's happy where she
lives she's happy with the people that
she works for um and she's not she's not
like an airhead at all you know she's
very much you know just she's very
blissful and she's very happy and she's
very simple and I really admire simple
people um I think there's always this
thing about like you know if a person
seems you know very simple as I go well
then they can't be good there's nothing
a simple person can offer us I just
think that's such bullshit you know
simple people you know keep their lives
very simple and not too complicated
because they know if things get too
complicated they get out of control and
when things are out of control that
creates stress when you create stress
you're not happy so that really makes
sense I just like that you know this
woman she's she found a good job she's
found uh you know good people to be with
and she just kind of enjoys herself it
that optimism it's that constant kind of
naive but also trying her best optimism
that I don't I really respect
Sarah Silverman from the Sarah Silverman
show and I know a lot of people like
this not accurate turns yes um I think
it's pretty obvious this woman knows
that like she can say all this really
shocking controversial stuff because she
plays kind of a dummy you know that's
just her thing she sort of plays like
the airhead who doesn't know any better
um so she can get away with it but you
know she doesn't know any better it's
just like nobody has taught her anything
um and I think I think this is one of
those cases where it is sort of more the
person behind the act I mean the
character herself it's still kind of
likable and that she's she's trying to
be good she thinks she has stuff figured
out and she's gonna enjoy life but she
clearly doesn't it just says terrible
stuff um but we'll also still kind of
try to learn I read this one episode
where is she it's so offensive I think
she's getting an argument with this
black guy she says well it's really hard
being Jewish and he says what's really
hard being black so they decide to
switch places and her dress up as a
black person and him as a a Jewish
person and both both the disguises are
the most offensive I mean most offensive
portrayals of a black person and a
Jewish person and again I I think it
works out okay cuz you know she's Jewish
and you know that when when she sees a
vert you know hidden portraying a Jewish
person I mean it's just like so terrible
but you know she's willing to make fun
of herself she and I really respect any
comedian who you know they can dish out
all this stuff you know making fun
people but they can take the exact same
amount back and they can throw it at
themselves just as hard anyone that
throws that kind of stuff out there if
they can also make the exact same joke
on themselves and do it often you know
which I think she does I think it works
um so yeah I think I think this is one
of those cases where I have more respect
for the person herself behind the
Silverman character Sarah Silverman
behind Sarah Silverman you know what I
mean um that she can just whip up this
character and be so confident
and say these really shocking face shock
humor is very difficult to do well and I
have a great respect for people I can do
it louis c.k is wonderful at it i think
sarah silverman is too and i really have
a great respect that they can just walk
that line but balance it out okay
and i think she does that very well and
i think there is just this sort of
liveliness and this experimentation with
what she can get away with and what she
can't uh you know if there's a little
bit of the tomboy element in there she's
usually wearing a jersey I know a lot of
times you see her kind of acting you
know dumb and like an airhead and stuff
and not all her material works either
but there's just something about how
smart she has constructed this character
to get away with all of this uh and why
we accept it and why we're okay with I
mean don't know everybody is but uh that
it is just a she doesn't know any better
but she's she thinks she's being
something really good and really
positive and actually she's being
something incredibly insulting but it's
but like she's really trying you always
see that in the persona that she creates
that you know she is just really trying
she's just talking about the stuff like
what isn't this how it is I mean isn't
and she'll sort of bring up these really
offensive things like well what what
that's that is how it is right is it and
the logic that she creates with that
character you do sort of go oh I can see
how doesn't this understanding what kind
of happen to a really stupid person but
you you understand you see how the
person even though they're not very
bright you see how they got to that
mindset or they thought about this very
offensive subject that they're talking
about so um yeah that this probably is a
case where I respect more the person
behind it and how she can get away with
all that uh but yeah it's very clever
very funny and she's already down
Nicolle Bihari from Sleepy Hollow I'm
sure I put you that name but something I
can't butcher is how awesome she is in
this show it is sort of the standard cop
showing the person out of touch and out
of time around it's the I always say
it's kind of like April O'Neil with a
gun
you know just showing the turtles around
like how the world works and stuff but
she's um what I like about her is that
even though it is or the very standard
safe character showing people around
with a tragic backstory that of course
the person she's showing around will
understand and will romance bloom of
course it will um but what I like about
her is that she even though she is
beautiful I'm just beautiful woman um
you never don't buy that she's a cop
like you believe it there's definitely
this this determination and this focus
even the tragic backstory that she's
given uh with her sister and nobody
believing her you still buy it you the
way she plays it off you totally buy
that they went through this and she's
sort of had to renounce her sister and
she's living with this guilt of doing
that and it's all there nothing about
her ever seems like you know just too
happy or too perky or hey I'm just here
to kind of be the eye candy thing like
she she really carries this role that is
honestly a very standard role but it's
the performance is what she brings to it
and she really brings a lot I think she
does it very very well um I think she's
she's great at being you know sort of
the salad to Ichabod in the show it's
this is a really stupid show but yeah
everybody knows that I think a lot of
people in saying like this is sort of
like the new Buffy in a sense I mean
maybe not quite like Buffy definitely
had like a real cult following and and
the stories got really complicated and
detailed and stuff um I think this is a
little bit more gimmicky than that
um but yeah I think they're still in it
wouldn't work if you just got somebody
who was only there to be attractive and
only there you know just to get you know
horny boys to watch or something as a
James Bond movie
with Denise Richards as a rocket
scientist or something like that we get
it it's James Bond all the women are
super attractive and hot spies and stuff
but uh you know it nobody was buying
this and you know she couldn't carry it
at all and I don't think it's just the
appearance I really don't I think that
there is still this weight that you can
bring to something where it sounds like
you know what you're talking about
and she didn't and to her credit a lot
of people saying this science
mumbo-jumbo and stuff you know can't
really bring that there's at you the
next movie of reviewing ah you'll see
there's another character I'm talking
about that cannot do the sci-fi mumbo
jumbo um so I don't think it's just oh
hey that person's too attractive so they
can't be smart I don't think that's it I
think there still has to be this
believability
and this woman gets it I think she
really does bring it and you see the
guilt in her uh when she has to think
about her past and confront it or when
she confronts her sister going back and
forth between how much of this ichabod
guy do I believe you know and how much
is just a crazy man uh and I think she
does a good job I think it's really
solid for a role that is so safe and
kind of predictable I think she really
brings a lot to it and I think she does
good
milla jovovich in the fifth element we
all know multipass and we all remember
the outfit that she worn this I swear
that doesn't play that big apart there's
just something so cute
about somebody trying to figure out how
things work that you obviously know you
know I love Bill Ted's Excellent
Adventure I love when all the historical
figures are tried there in the mall and
I'm just trying to figure out how the
world operates it I love that stuff I
just think that stuff is a lot of fun
and it's really cute and when you have
um you know this woman come in who's
sort of like an animal that's counting
on her guard and just doesn't know
what's going on I love it when they put
her in the shower it's going up and
she's just looking around and very
animalistic uh it's just really fun to
watch especially you know a lot of stuff
it's not harmful um and when she finally
learns the language and can kind of talk
and it's I don't know
that definitely went through a phase to
Y really liked women with like different
colored dyed hair like the really weird
colors you know of course that orange
color and the Supreme Being has orange
dreads I mean like bright orange it's
like okay there's this innocence to her
like I said just trying to figure out
the world that there was definitely you
know there was the badass qualities in
there too you know she would constantly
you know get in fights and you know
whatever it jumped through stuff and it
constantly jumping off of stop off of
cliffs and stuff um and she was
obviously super strong cuz she would
crash through cars and walls and so
forth um and there's it'll serve just a
fun mix of both kind of badass but kind
of innocent and sweet and I don't know
there's just something that maybe there
is sort of like that protective
nourishment or whatever it in man or in
me anyway that's just like you know it's
okay here's how this works and here's
how but then she can also go kick ass
and be like here we go rock on so I
don't know it's a fun mix it's um the
only time she gets a little knowing is
at the end when she's like you know oh
we're bad I don't want to save humanity
because they have Wars beginning of the
movie the big turtle people come and
avoid war is coming we must stop it is
like you
what warriors so you hid it on earth to
protect it from war so whatever shits
going on with us you guys have had it
much worse so yeah that was weird and
pretty stupid but the movie is stupid
but I love it it's a great fun dumb
movie um so yeah I can't think of too
much else to say about it um just a fun
character and I thought you did a great
job
Natalie would in the great race oh my
god she okay so not only is the
character awesome I mean this is like
when was this made like in the 60s or
something like that and it's about a lot
to say the thirties and yeah I want to
say like the 20s and 30s the 60s and the
20s and this character is like a super
strong feminist like she's fighting for
the vote and she's trying to be
emancipated and she's trying to you know
go out there and say you know come on
woman's you know out of the kitchens
into the workplace and so on she's not
annoying I think there is something
about any cause I mean any cause at all
when you constantly get the wagging
finger I think there's something about
you know well we're not there yet and
this is wrong and this is wrong and this
is wrong and there's only so much
bawling out somebody can hear uh when
really what you want is that you do want
to acknowledge one of the problems but
you also want a celebration about what's
good about your cause and that's why I
love Natalie Wood in this she's so smart
but she's also so charming and she's so
optimistic and she really believes and
she's constantly smiling and she's
loving what she's doing she's so
enjoying fighting for this cause because
she knows who she is she knows what
she's fighting for and she knows it's a
good thing and she has this thought that
they're going to win it's like yes it'll
take a while but we're on her way it's
gonna happen because she is so certain
about her cause and she's so certain
about herself there's that great
confidence in that character with her
there's just this great celebration of
who she is and what she's fighting for
they always give her these really fun
outlandish outfits I know there's one
where they're like there in the cold and
she's where I swear this Eskimo outfit
yet somehow this curl still comes out of
the side and it's always there it's
always like you know it's not something
that naturally sort happen if somebody
had to gel it out for something and it's
really funny um and yeah it's sort of
this she saw this really big great
celebration of femininity and and
Natalie Wood is wonderful this so easily
could have been just an annoying
performance it could have been someone
who did nothing but you know complain
and wave the finger but
she just has this lust for life and what
she's doing that it's just it's
irresistible Nelly would in that movie
uh just man she's great
Michelle Pfeiffer from Batman Returns
this is a totally different Catwoman
from the comics the cartoons the TV
shows NER Catwoman has ever been done
before so I know it's not following like
the original vision but with that said
this version I think is awesome I love
just how freakin crazy she is but I also
love how driven she is I think it's the
contrast of who she was against who
she's become and what she's trying to be
you know it she doesn't even know what
she's trying to be she's just falls out
of a building and she just wakes up and
how do you accept that how do you treat
that how do you know and it just
obviously just totally went to her head
and she went insane but it's that
struggle between sanity and insanity and
you know sort of good and evil and and
where you lie and at the same time not
being taken advantage of it no it's just
a great character uh show Pfeiffer plays
a great um it good God is pretty damn
attractive
I like it because you can look at you
don't necessarily say like you know
oh that goth you know or whatever that's
just like you know there's definitely
like a finished thing in there but I
don't know that the little crosshatch is
of the little stitches across those are
so strange and so weird and kind of
creepy and kind of offsetting like a
Frankenstein monster that was put back
together and that's kind of what she is
somebody who died is brought back so I
love that I mean I just thought that was
you know so unique uh and just very
piercing to the eye we just see those
white stitches stand out um with five or
herself uh the the look it's still very
feminine because you know they give it a
really big eye shadow on the the lips
day all that stuff but she's also kind
of falling apart through the movie too
and the outfits getting ripped up more
and you know
her hair's going crazy and she's just
kind of turning it more and more into
this beast I don't know in terms of why
that's attractive um when she first
comes out and and she does the voice the
very seductive voice like she's got
stuff figured out and she's in control
she's just gonna do whatever the hell
she wants she knows what she does not
want to be anymore which is you know her
old self you know the the secretary
taking orders and stuff and I think when
she comes out she knows no more I don't
know what I want to be or what exactly I
want to do or become but I know it's not
this that is gone you know now I'm just
gonna experiment and not give a shit
what anybody thinks I'm just gonna do
what I want um and and that that's great
fun again I think it is a little bit of
that confidence that confidence on
taking a chance you know just totally
giving up on what anybody thinks a fiber
herself even when she's not like in the
catsuit outfit she just looks beautiful
in this movie the the scene where she's
dancing with Bruce Wayne and stuff I
mean she just looks beautiful there um
and she plays it so well I mean she is
just that same scene I think that's her
tour best when she's dancing with
Michael Keaton there and you know
there's a point where he's like you know
the hell do you think you are and she
starts to break down and it's like she's
looking in as a cry for help and she
says I don't know anymore Bruce and then
like as soon as like the camera pans
over and you see the back of Keith's
head and then it comes around she's
laughing like she was just never crying
or never looking sad at all and she's
just like you know really giggling
really laughing it's just so nuts but
God she does it so well and I don't know
it's just I'd be fascinated to know how
that mine ticks and but again there's
there's sort of that lost element that
you know if maybe somebody can help her
maybe Batman can help her find the way
cuz it's clearly kind of nuts too he
dresses up like a bad and everything so
he thinks that he can help her but she
might be too far gone but is she is she
not and so I I love it I it's a
fascinating character I love the take on
it and it I just think it's awesome
Emilia Clarke from Game of Thrones yes
Daenerys she no fucking love didn't ever
she is so awesome um she just takes
everything you know for her own and she
and she does it smart and she listens to
people but she you know she's also kind
of learning and when she learns
something it's like you know what she
she sticks by it and she I that's
Daenerys the mother of dragons man I
love how far she's come I love what she
started out as and what she has done
with it I love love-love-love characters
that can take something that was a
disadvantage and just turn it into this
unbelievable strength and that's
something Game of Thrones done so well
um you know I love Daenerys I love I
love Tyrion and I love Arya cuz they've
all done that and that is just such
strength and it's just such something to
respect and I really love this character
for that um I like a lot of people and
waiting for it to get going you know
like okay come on let's some you know
well when are we really gonna start
taking over the world here you know just
very very slowly but I still love her I
love watching her I love watching her
learn I love watching her definitely
being controlled being power but there
is definitely this sympathy uh you know
when true wrong is being done I love it
when she takes all the people that they
hung up which was like you know it was
the kids I think uh going to this
village is to scare people off and she
takes every single one of them down you
know when going there when taking over
this village and but the same time you
know it's like it's just fueling the
anger that's building up inside of her
and how she's gonna like teach this town
a lesson um
and it's great she you know is she's a
she's obviously a badass and you see her
become a badass I love how you take this
situation where she's just with this
brute you know that this brute king I
mean just this you know
quit savage and she she knows she can't
defeat him I mean this guy's like just a
fucking monster so she tries to sort of
psychologically you know win him over
like hey I'm not just a prize let's
actually sort of work things out here
and she does it in the way the guy can
understand and she sort of starts to
take control and sir shows like in of
this seat this isn't so bad we can work
with it and you just so brilliantly you
see her win him over but then genuinely
fall in love with him uh and it's this
really it's the stranger thing it's like
how the hell do you have a romance like
an actual kind of believable romance
start with rape I mean that is how this
starts you see or do it you see step by
step how she does it and I love
characters that can just start at the
bottom and can slowly but surely build
their way up I mean this is a problem
like someone you know isn't nobody and
starts all offense nothing is suddenly
given all this power suddenly given all
this attention you know I see some HL
stars going you know is that that's not
how it should be done it's not quite
earned and it's not given the time to
let the actions that you're doing sink
in and to have you learn what works and
what doesn't uh and that's why I love
stories like this we see them just start
it's such a horrible place to start and
slowly get stronger and stronger and
smarter and smarter and learn and learn
and make mistakes and either definitely
mistakes made and she just turns into
something awesome it's so powerful but
also you know she's she's trying to
fight for the right things I mean you
see how awful this world can be I mean
and just the tyrants that rule it and
she's granted very badass and having her
dragons blow people up and you know get
her armies together and but there is
still service she still wants to rule
the fairly and she told the people she's
gonna leave and get treat you with
dignity and respect so it's like I I
really fought see this woman win
Alessi her win she's just awesome
fucking Daenerys Daenerys rocks that's
all
Catherine zeta-jones from the mask of
Zoro yeah I know big shock nobody saw
this coming um yeah sorry I am so
predictable um a lot of people are
wondering uh when I was talking about
the list cuz everyone I told I was gonna
do this list it's like well we know
what's gonna be number one you know but
is it gonna be Chicago is it gonna be
Zorro its Zorro because that was the
very first time I saw her and it is a
fun character it's a character who um
you know was brought up in riches and
being raised by the bad guy but at the
same time you know can sword fight and
still sort of hold her own actually is
something I really like is there is a
line in the movie where you know Antonio
Banderas is trained by the original
Zorro uh and then he goes any fights
Catherine zeta-jones she is she's been
having the proper training since she was
four she said and so you would think
it's like why was this guy who's been
trained I don't know couple months of it
really intensely but still trained a
couple months how can he defeat someone
who's been trained since she was friggin
four and he doesn't really that's what I
like about it she actually defeats him
but then when it gets to working without
the swords like you know he has to use
the objects around him and stuff that is
where she's defeated and that makes
sense a person learning fencing wouldn't
be taught you know well now you have to
learn when you're going out being a
vigilante to use other surroundings
around ease that probably wouldn't be
taught in fencing or maybe it is out no
but it certainly taught much more
d'asaro because he has to do it too you
know to survive you know do what he does
you know she doesn't so I really like
that I really respect that um but that's
not the only thing uh the and I know a
lot this is movie magic
um because there is something about the
way they did her makeup in this movie
she has never looked as good as she has
in this movie and Kevin see it Jones is
beautiful I mean she is just like
goddamn you are fucking beautiful you're
unbelievable by God um even though
that's like I know she's getting up here
but she's still
it's really good um and she's a decent
actress - I think she you know Chicago
she dealt uh singing and dancing and I
totally bought it and believed it um but
the uh yeah I think the the makeup job
they did in this there's a deleted scene
in the Zorro DVD if you watch it you see
how it looks before the filters are put
on and you know the makeup plays a big
part because before the filters are put
on and then just moving it out and
whatever she looks really weird not her
natural face I talked about the makeup
looks really really odd especially
around the nose there's this really
weird thing they're doing I don't know
what it is I'm not makeup person but
it's definitely in effect that's why
that's another reason why I said very
much this is movie characters you know
it's not the actresses themselves I mean
they bring a lot of course probably the
majority but it's still the characters
because I know it's a movie I know it's
an illusion and I know the characters
aren't real and I'm attracted to the
illusion of these people Cary Grant the
beer but ah bitch tells a story about
how Cary Grant tried to get him in a
party you know kind of crashing it and
the woman's like name and he says Cary
Grant and she looks at him and says you
don't look like Cary Grant a he says I
know nobody does not even me and it's
very true you know it's not even John
Wayne can be John Wayne it's like the
image it's just so the illusion is so
built up so I get that that's one of the
reasons I very much want to make this
you know the characters not the actual
people because I never met these people
um but yeah there's just this that Zorro
movie as well came at a time I talked
about before where there was just I want
to say it was like Batman and Robin up
to probably Zora maybe I honestly maybe
a year after Zorro cos aura was like the
one movie because there was a solid
three or four years where we just never
got a good summer movie summer movies
were expected to suck and we just
accepted it and it was awful as this
really was like and I movies go through
walls and hills and valleys I get it and
production companies and stuff but this
was like
we leave the dark times of summer movies
you know in another whatever I'm
Christmas and stuff made some good moves
to come out but summer movies were just
dead I mean they were fucking dead and
anyone that says all summer movies are
so bad now and no they from Batman
return a Batman and Robin to whatever uh
I try to think where the really big
turning point happened um from Batman
Robin up until about three or four years
after that we had nothing but shit and
it was just expected we were gonna go
see our summer movies they were gonna
suck nothing we can do
um maybe they aren't let's change then I
don't know but it was the discovery CG
and it really sucked and Zorro came out
like the same years armed again deep
impact perfect storm all that lucky shit
they were all terrible and Zorro came
out and it was sword fighting and it was
stunts and it was characters and it was
good story and it was you know new
people you know we don't really saw
Catherine zeta-jones before we saw a
little bit of Antonio Banderas but he
was up and coming and the villains
nobody saw before and it was like the
most refreshing movie it was saying yes
summer movies can be good again and it
was just yes like that that was the big
point so yeah so in when she and she was
just like that blooming like that
blossoming that hey summer movies can be
good again and there can be new people
you haven't seen before they can just
win you over and they can be talented
and they can be fun and they can be
energized and they can be charming and
they can be romantic and the romance in
the film is very believable
uh and I like how she's kind of playing
Zorro you know but she's also trying to
stand by her father who is kind of bad
guy too and the UH that chemistry in
that movie between zero and her it's
just like you know oh my god the sword
fight it's just it's just hot it's hot
there's nothing else I can say about it
um so yeah I I still think Catherine
zeta-jones is beautiful and I think
she's talented all but in terms of
what's the movie that was just like just
blew me away
in terms of just attractiveness and
and energized and and interesting and
out it that's the one that that's just
like man everybody was blown away to
everyone when that movie came out was
just like who is this woman who we gotta
figure out who this woman is because
this is like she was so beautiful it was
like a punch in the face I me it was
like where the hell did this woman come
from so yeah that's I'm sorry I have a
no I'm not sorry this is why you watch
the video you want to see me gush uh so
yeah it's um it's Catherine zeta-jones
man it's uh and that's the movie you
know that's the movie where the illusion
and the the likability of the character
and the movie and the scenario and the
action and the visuals and everything
just came together and I really think
she was one of the main centers of of
that explosion of the illusion that that
is a very attractive movie the movie as
far as action films go it's one of the
most attractive action movies because
everything is in it there's dancing
there's sword fighting there's drama
there's comedy there's beautiful people
there's ugly people there's you know
that there's uh this grittiness to it
it's not for kids it's not entirely for
adults either it's kind of for everyone
but it's it's it's turning into just
this big praising of the movie but
really I'm talking more about the praise
of the illusion and that's really what
this list I felt was it's the praising
of the illusion of what what we want to
be and what we're looking for um and
yeah I don't see any shame of that I see
no shame and talking about what draws
you to a person what are good trays what
are good qualities um what do you like
visually what do you like inside um I
see no fault in talking about it so guys
that's my list um who are some of the
characters that you find attractive
whether it be TV shows or movies
whatever uh and how much of it do you
think is the actors and how much of it
do you think is the actual writing
itself um or directing or whatever so
leave in the comments below talk about
it um because I think it's a fun thing
to talk about you know if you're a woman
talk about the guys you find attractive
you know
if you think it's the actor or the or
the writing directing all this stuff you
know explore talk about it um yeah guys
that's about it next week there'll be a
new NC review it'll be a full review
won't be an editorial and I will see you
guys then take care
I forgot to mention if you're gay or bi
also go ahead and leave that below too
you know I didn't mention that in there
but you know what I should I definitely
should so um yeah I attraction is fun go
ahead leave your thoughts talk about it
and what it is the attraction to those
people so that's about it and take care